herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
heute zusammen mit sebastian und werden
alles funktioniert meiner schwester
werden unsere schwestern in dem auto
über das gesicht gelegt weil wir sie
nicht zeigen würden so kannst du
trotzdem ein video mit machen und wir
gucken wir uns heute beziehungsweise
unsere schwester guckt sich heute unsere
instagram die ems an
ich will sagen ich beginne mit der
ersten nachricht und zwar folgende
bereiche
ich habe von normalen keks in meiner
tasche 1000 gern einmal genau abliefert
wir sind so die ganz normalen kräfte die
man überall kaufen kann so direkt
huskies werfen könnte der setzte leben
also das war also wo ich überhaupt nicht
in die richtung gemacht hatte
diese nachricht hat überhaupt keinen
kontext wird mir vollkommen aus nicht
gerade groß ist ich wollte gerade danach
fragen was du dem spielbetrieb wird also
wirklich komplett ohne kontext leute
dann kann euch wirklich die besten immer
beste video ab wie stellst du dir das
eigentlich im allgemeinen sofort wie
glaubst du gehst ist so ich sag mal
berühmt in zwei jahren führungs zeiten
zu sein dass man so viel inspirierendes
von unbekannten leuten kommen wie stellt
sich das pool oder durch also ich würde
es ja ihr habt mir das so gesagt da ist
dir eigentlich gerne so nachrichten
bekommt aber das hier nicht immer darauf
antwortet weile anhalten
das ist eine erfahrung die man gemacht
hat so super gerne würde ich einfach
leute wie man mal wieder antworten und
sowas aber das ding ist sobald man halt
einmal geschrieben hat und kann es auch
voll verstehen kriegt man halt immer
wieder nach also man schreibt so jemand
so hey ich hab ne frage sagt mir was los
ist und dann stellte ich das nicht
beantworten ist und einen creekside in
zwei jahren nachricht wenn die leute
einmal zugelassen sind beides juli
fixiert immer wie
und da wir auch privat nutzen ist es
immer track gibt ja und darüber dass man
halt 40 50 jets offen so mit leuten
jemals gekannt hat und die schreiben an
alle zwei wochen
irgendwas das wahrscheinlich ein
standpunkt wir uns ein bisschen fehlen
guck mal hier
du siehst so aussieht dann bruder findet
uns eigentlich nicht dass er damit
bastian ähnlich weil eben diese bist ja
eben macht doch was gesagt wird
ja okay alles klar ich habe letztes jahr
ein video gemacht indem ich mich über so
eine frau besser analysiert habe die
süchtig nach und dann schaffen wir
jemanden auch wenn es sogar mit diesen
tag x vor habe gerade sein neues video
geguckt mit der süchtigen taucher seien
und ein oberteil ist ganz neues aber
sieht bisschen schwul andy rouse
vielleicht bist du schwul was mega okay
ist wollte ich dir nur mit können diese
im prinzip nichts sagen also ich besorge
einfach geschrieben so seien über
twitter tun hast du hast du das video
gesehen
weil ich gegen den videoinhalt generell
höhere geworden
alles klar wir haben absolute klassiker
hey ich na ja weil das sind so trick
fragen so geht man aber davon ersten mal
gecheckt und hey wie es ist und diese im
bild sein wird bei hertha ließ das gold
oder aktien und dargestellt oder ich
muss dir was sagen so das kriegt man so
ganz
bisher ließ ist ja ähnlich also ich muss
sagen wirklich ich lese den größten teil
meiner in zürich nicht an fachleuten
nicht aus dem viele aber jeder alles aus
dem hier schreibt das okay aber jetzt da
ich liebe nach das ist gar nicht
irgendwie was lustiges oder so ich habe
mich einfach absolut in dieses lächeln
verliebt ich hoffe sehr es geht ihr gut
und du gehst deinen weg weiter so wie du
es bis jetzt getan hat kann es
unglaublich stolz auf dich sein ohne
wird's richtig wohl fühlen sagt was
sagst du zu finden wenn dein bruder
solche nachrichten bekommen ich habe da
kein problem mit allerdings wir werden
die ganze zeit verändert jetzt von euch
vor
und es ist so nervig abend kam es weil
du unter volks und an der grenze
wird muss das du dass du bist ja bisher
natürlich auch er ich hoffe ja
zwischendurch hatte einfach vergessen
schau dort ankomme hatte bei dem ich mir
abgeguckt mit dem lg
wenn es funktioniert richtig coole
möglichkeit haben übrigens keine 3 ps
bist du noch mit jahren zusammen jahr
wir sind alle drei männer zusammen was
für ein glück im blut nächsten die wir
heute kennen zurzeit liefen in positur
noch nie ein handy mit diesem update
wird hier also dazu muss man sagen es
ist eine last von der persönlich nicht
kennen
passt ja wir kennen uns jetzt schon so
lange
deshalb wollte ich fragen habe zu hause
sagen das waren so zu jobs über gemacht
aber so anträge und so dass anträge den
21 bekommen aber eher kleiner schlawiner
was sagst du dazu an dieser stelle
wenn ihr bock ab 200 einfach wenn die
bordkarten aktiv an dieser stelle wäre
keine [ __ ] wurde habe ich bin immer
wissen will 3sat auch sehr gute frage
was ist dein lieblings habe ich meine es
ist wenigstens doch er hat mir nicht so
einen anderen ort so anders die
konversation anzufangen weiß
der war solo ich nehme direkt noch
einmal ein foto von mir hier gesehen
habe mich nicht getraut sich
anzusprechen
ich verstehe schon aber eigentlich steht
ist den max weniger als es nicht wenn
das war wirklich wie weit wir sind
letztes jahr da waren meine mutter und
schwester zu besuchen in köln bei uns
und wir sind über die straße gelaufen
und haben zumindest so lange konnten so
über mich ich habe und dann gucken dich
so 50.000 menschen so lange jetzt nicht
essen oder sollten sie auch keines hat
man durch den ganzen mcdonald's
geschrieben dass sie sebastian erkannt
da waren wir an der raststätte und das
volleyball wissenschaft also irgendwie
sind alle so richtig ausgelassen das
haben wir gar nicht so oft bei uns ist
das nicht so kraft und plötzlich ist das
so eine ganze volleyballmannschaften die
wenn man alle sofort zu uns macht wurde
und jeder in ihrer schlanken hat uns
angeguckt und dann erkennst du die mich
das sind doch youtuber und so alle leute
grillen scheiterte man sagen wir sind
bereit dem boden verseucht nur so 34
zuschauer das so und dann hat seine
ganze schlange mit allen möglichen
leuten ja doch der autobahn essen so
kann aber mich vertreter so familien
rentner und dann rufen die das sind
youtuber alle dringlich und tänze wird
hey ich will an tragen oder hier ich
habe meinen account abgecheckt also dem
nächsten selbst geschrieben hat ist es
so ich liebe personen so voll das brave
so deutsch aussehende mädchen beschreibt
scheint er es wirklich gerne beiden aber
das ist auch nicht das finde ich auch
richtig geil ist seit zwei jahren keinem
einkommen videos hochgeladen möglichkeit
ist echt so keck sofort von ihr aber
nicht für übrigen hat der mensch
fernsehen schaue mir gerade ein neues
video an
schön samstag das sq man fühlt sich das
duo allerdings so jemand besser gemacht
auch jeden das ist richtig schön so was
zu lesen also keine ahnung wann kriegt
kommen
also von zeit zu zeit kriegt man es
richtig süßes nach wo man sie aber denkt
so geil dass ich das mache was ich mache
und irgendwie da haben leute spaß haben
und freuen sich darüber dass ist
wirklich schön zu sehen dass ich ärger
mich bilden tag leute schlechter machen
okay ich bin auf meine accounts ist
laura und mein bruder hat auch laura
scott lago
man konnte zwei jahren schon haben wir
unsere schwester einerseits weiter und
damit man sagen abschließend was sagst
du zu den instrumenten von benno nicht
das waren jetzt die weniger schlimm
es gibt schlimmere ja ich habe in der
schule haben computer wir haben
computerraum und einer von meinen
freunden hat euch gegoogelt und ich sag
mal so es war fan fiction hab es nicht
lesen wollen
sechstens gucken wir uns eigentlich
stoppen aber das ist ja unangenehm sagte
kummer überlegt mal wenn ihr sowas
schreibt das lesen freunde von unserer
schwester in der schule als potters das
natürlich so eine sache für sich
aber ich muss wirklich sagen das war
schon ein guter querschnitt von unseren
instrumenten also in der regel schreiben
die leute sowas sowie hey ich hätte
meine frage oder dass sie einen
sympathisch finden so was also ich muss
mich sagen eigentlich haben wir oder ich
kann nur für mich selbst nimmt sich
verhält wie somit mit der community
niemand der so stressig wie man seit
[ __ ] und man wird nicht aus
man würde nicht mal wirklich beleidigt
oder sowas muss man einfach liebe nette
leute und auf jeden fall haben wir
bleibt stabil
ich würde sagen dass war zum heutigen
video get there sa haus vor daraus neues
geld zu machen ok safran heute bleibt
abzuwarten
[Musik]